Westeros has mighty rivers but none of
them compare to the Rhoyne it is said
that there is no stream or puddle in
western esses but drains to mother
Rhoyne no doubt an exaggeration until
one sees the river at its widest a man
in the center can't see ashore to either
side the greatest of mother Rhoyne
children were the Rhoyne er a
civilization as ancient and grand as old
keys fishers traders scholars workers of
wood stone and metal the Royer raised
their elegant cities from the headwaters
of the Rhoyne down to her mouth each
lovelier than the last for many
centuries the Rana lived in relative
peace when invaders swept down from the
hills the Reuter women and men would Don
silver scaled Armour fishhead Helms tall
Spears and turtle shell shields if the
enemy did not laugh themselves away it
was said that mother Rhoyne would
whisper the enemy's secrets to her
children and the rhoynish wizards could
raise watery walls to drown their foes
whatever magic the roya may have had it
wasn't enough when Valyrian colonists
first arrived their owner embraced and
for all men were welcomed to share the
bounty of mother Rhoyne perhaps a water
people should have been more cautious of
strangers who exalted fire and blood
legend has it that one day the Valyrians
netted and butchered one of the giant
turtles the Rhoyne are held sacred as a
result thousands were killed or enslaved
cities and towns were burned to drowned
and rebuilt in these wars the Valerians
emerged as victorious more often than
not the princes of the royal cities
fiercely proud of their independence
fought alone whilst the Valyrian
colonies aided one another
eventually the rhoynish princes ceased
their squabbling and united behind
prince garin
who led the largest army Essos had ever
seen against a hundred thousand Valyrian
colonists a hundred war elephants and
three Dragonlords thousands burned but
thousands more sheltered in the shallows
of the river whilst the rhoynish wizards
raised enormous water spouts against the
foes dragons
Roy nish archers brought down two of the
Dragons whilst the third fled wounded
and thereafter the Rhoyne are named
Garen the great but mother Valyria
proved just as caring as mother Rhoyne
when Garen the Great marched his army
against volantis three hundred Valyrian
dragons descended from the sky tens of
thousands burned whilst others rushed
into the river but the fires burned so
hot that the water boiled and turned to
steam Garen the Great was captured alive
and made to watch as Valerians butchered
every last man so many that their blood
turned the great harbor of volantis red
as far as the eye could see then they
forced Garen to watch as they marched on
his own city and enslaved all the women
and children his army had left behind
the singers claimed that prince garin
called out mother Rhoyne to curse the
Valerians and she in turn flooded the
city with foul waters and a damp fog
that caused the skin of the Valerians to
harden and crack and thus was born
greyscale fearing a similar fate
another rhoynish ruler princess Nymeria
led her own people into every ship skiff
and raft they had and fled Essos
eventually after much hardship they
landed in sun-swept
and bone-dry dawn but we all know that
tale now Valyria has followed the Rhoyne
are out of this world and her daughters
have grown into free cities wealthy and
powerful and proud still mother Rhoyne
flows on past ancient ruins and bustling
harbors sweeping all man's kingdoms to
the sea